i feel like it must be a little bit of a
relief to now
that the the remainder of the season's
out you can actually talk about
everything as opposed to having to keep
like zipped lips on spoilers
yeah well i guess we've been sat on it
for a while you know so it's nice to
kind of have it all out there definitely
that does bring me to my first question
for you which is at what point in the
production did you personally learn
about eddie's fate and what would happen
kind of uh during the pandemic
there was um
i got a couple of texts from the
brothers
asking if i played guitar
and then we got the script for seven
eight and nine uh just before we kind of
started back so i kind of knew his fades
before we kind of started filming really
was it like was it a case of something
that was kept from any other cast for a
while or did you pretty much find out
when they all found out when scripts
went out
i think we all found out at the same
time yeah i don't think there was any
kind of um secrets or anything no no one
was kind of keeping anything from anyone
um
yeah we'll we all knew uh
i'm glad you brought up the playing
guitar thing because that does bring me
to one of my favorite moments i think
for eddie in this in these last two
episodes which is the scene where he
plays the guitar to attract the demo
bats away from vekna so they can kind of
you know orchestrate that whole plan so
did you have to learn guitar for that
scene or was it a case of you know i'm
curious as to how much you had to do for
that well um it's kind of
it was a combination of both really i've
played guitar since i was very young so
i was lucky that i had a kind of
foundation there um but as i said kind
of when i read the scripts the next
morning i went out and bought a guitar
and kind of like manically started
learning
um master of puppets and then kind of
on the day
um me and gayden just kind of got up on
top of the um the campervan and kind of
uh
yeah just kind of got into it it was
very fun i played most of it there was
um we got a kind of black belt
uh kind of metal guitarist to come in
and do the solo because i'm i'm a human
being
to play that it's very
very fast um but the rest of it i kind
of like to try try my best to kind of um
have a stab at um it's very fun
so that so that song was in the script
from the beginning they knew what song
they wanted for that moment so you kind
of knew like how to prep specifically
for that tune it was always that song it
was you know it was like like everything
in this season they i think they knew
what they wanted and how they were going
to do it and they executed it
brilliantly yeah one thing that really
struck me about these last two episodes
for your character specifically eddie
and dustin's friendship i think really
reaches a meaningful point for both of
them you know but there's an obvious
weight to those scenes too as we see
later but these are scenes that we just
get to see you and dayton together
you know performing and really kind of
giving your all so i'm curious if the
two of you did you did you do anything
on set kind of in between those moments
to really break up the tension or
lighten the mood
or did you just kind of go into it and
and let yourself really feel the
heaviness in those moments
i mean we definitely weren't kind of
like taking it home with us or anything
i think it was just kind of and it's
seemed like any other scene um but it's
just yeah there's a kind of depth there
that isn't there
most days when you're at work um but i i
i don't think we were doing kind of
anything kind of um
in between takes to kind of make sure
that we kind of got there or anything
uh it was
just
yeah we just kind of just kind of gummed
it i think yeah
i mean i think the results speak for
themselves but i but i really enjoyed
kind of getting to see the two of you
have more of those moments of emotional
poignancy and also i think the fact that
like
you see these two friends who were able
to say that they love each other
in that moment and i think there's
something really meaningful to that that
the show was like we can show platonic
love you know between these two guys in
the sense that you know it really hits
home so um
well i think then you know there are all
different kinds of flavors of love and i
think
um men sometimes struggle to kind of
talk about that
um
and yeah i think kind of i mean i
personally i definitely have kind of
like older people like kind of guys in
my life who i kind of admired and
definitely had this kind of fraternal
love towards
and i felt that from them too and i
think kind of like that's what me and
gayson kind of wanted to kind of
uh convey
with our kind of um storyline really so
um
yeah i'm glad that that could actually
come across i know that you've gone on
record as saying that you would love to
come back for season five but that was
also before we found out about a certain
fate you know for eddie um but even with
that in mind i feel like there still
could be some possibility so
provided you got the call would you be
would you be in for showing up for one
more season
yeah i mean i don't know how they do it
but yeah i'd love to come back um
it feels like his
his face might be pretty um
yeah
it speaks for itself i think um but uh
if there was a world in which i don't
know i could kind of be
yeah a fly on the wall or something i
don't know um
i think
my suspicion is that they've got enough
characters to kind of grapple with at
the moment so um i think
they might have got um what they needed
out of eddie but um it was a pleasure to
be here you know even if it was only for
one season
i mean i personally would make a pitch
for like eddie as dustin's force ghost
or something like i was thinking
something like that it's like become his
conscience or something yeah definitely
um
but on that note i am actually all out
of time thank you so much for for your
time um chatting with me about the show
today and it's it's been great to watch
you this season so look forward to maybe
potentially force ghost uh eddie we'll
see
see let's see please meet connie thank
you
you